I'm so all-in entrepreneur I prefer the
pain I love the climb to me the setback
is exciting I love when something goes
wrong it's where I shine the most but
that's not for everybody right I mean it
can be very difficult and when you start
affecting your life and your loved ones
and all the other things it can get real
nasty to me the way I handle things even
though the few rare days when I really
struggle I take a real step back and
make pretend that somebody called me and
told me that my mother or daughter were
killed and I know that's very dark and I
apologize but it's really what I do I
literally am able to at my deepest most
struggling moment within business take a
step back and remind myself that I can
make a trillion dollars tomorrow on
Bitcoin and and if something bad
happened to the people I love the most
that it would mean nothing and it very
consistently rewires me very quickly
I just put business in perspective at
the end of the day you know it's it's
money for me it's not really money it's
my legacy so I get hurt by it a little
bit more but uh yeah I mean it's you
know I put in perspective it's money and
you know what up until I had a daughter
even while I was married up until when I
had Misha four years ago I secretly
wanted to lose all my money I had this
weird twisted dark fantasy of losing
everything just to rise again like a
phoenix and remind you [ __ ]